hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mapping cell states from
single cell gene expression data
presented by GC young MD associate
professor at the department of
biostatistics and computational biology
at Dana Farber Cancer Institute in
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
I'm Julie simmer off of Webber's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries roberts is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
launch the window to click on the screen
icon located on the lower right if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the lower left corner that
follows the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Wong I will now turn the presentation
over to him Thank You Julie for the
introduction thanks I'd like to first
thank you neighborhood so for the
opportunity to present our work here and
thank the audience that for
participating
so our work I'm going to present today
is about the single-cell analysis when
we look at the universe
we think this is the infinitely
complicated maybe Porsche pit and we
studied it and week stories about them
but actually every one of us there is
internal universe we composed of the
many men itself in fact the cells we
have it everybody is much more than the
number of the galaxies that in the
universe over the years many people have
studied the tissues that the cells
incidence of course and we know that our
body composes of itself various the
tissues cell types and the roughly
speaking these cells can be organized
into this hierarchy and starting from
top which is the of self-renewal stem
cells which and there goes these periods
of this differentiation become these the
terminology fresh itself which usually
carries out these everyday function
which of the cell types has its own
function and is all morphology and the
very beginning way people start to
recognize these the kind of the cell
types leases through really looking at
the cells at the microscopic level and
they actually this is the one of the
artists a figure tune from the famous
neurologist kaha who actually used can
read and draw these pictures of the
neurons and the he identify these
different subclasses of morals and
imagine that this way of the annotation
is not only labor-intensive but it's
also a subjected to a lot of these a
human error and the modern days the
people's going to realize the power to
use the molecular signatures to identify
these cell types and perhaps is one of
the most well designed the cellular
hierarchies with democratic systems and
the seminal work by the dr. Irvin
Weissman telephone Stanford over the
years and
many others people's that have
constructed for the linkage between this
humid aquatic systems relate based on
the ability that they can purify and
assorted the cells based on these so
called that the cell cervix mockers and
that's the kind of the tools that people
used in their labs almost every single
day but that the tooth nonetheless still
contain a lot of ambiguity as I will
show an elevator layer so in the past
few years there's a sin of these new
tools emerges called the single cell at
technology and what it does is that they
can use the inner to PCR of the RAC mess
country and all of these tools and they
can accurate the comma side is a
presumption level of the protein level
at the single cell resolution and with
that information people have been
equipped ative with this most powerful
tools trying to identify the cell types
it can develop a data scientist
development egg trays they identify
these heterogeneity insight diseases and
so on and so forth and one we started
this several years ago we applied to
these sensible cell technology to read
sunny the cellular hierarchy inside this
inhibit deposit system this is done by
the qpcr technology we look at the mouse
system we looking at the expression
level of this 280 common sense with mix
markers expression level in about 1500
of the single cells and what you can see
first is that these cells indeed group
into these big clusters of like what
they expected but within each of the
cell group then you look at them closely
and actually used to see
they're so quite a bit of the Hillary
and what that suggests is that these
common met tool using this exact sorting
technique is not capable at that data
firing distance subtle differences among
these indeed key sometimes so what I'm
going to tell you today is about our
work in the past few years to develop
the several computational methods trying
to ni that this is a single cell data
and the to characterize this is
sometimes dynamics and the lineages and
I will go into this in more details the
first method is called the Gini cost the
goal of that is trying to identify the
special types this works was led by a
very talented postdoc sat on one gel and
we are very motivated by the rapid
growth in the scale of the single-cell
analysis and you can see this figure
during the past few years the number of
the salesmen can profile by the single
technology almost the growing
exponentially and just a very recently
the internet genomics and released a big
data set that contains about 1.3 million
the single cells and from the almost the
grain systems and it will be really
really interesting trying to understand
among these data sets are there any cell
types in the now previous level and that
is kind of the drink in the single cell
about allergy so the kind of the
question to identify this lingual cells
is kind of the very similar to identify
a rare person inside these populations
so you are either looking at this
picture we probably would immediately
focus there is a person wearing red in
the middle and from that regard we
probably call him as a rare individual
but if you think about it the way that
we actually
and then insight is rare individuals
from this population is by no means and
trivial task because this person not
only look just about the same as
everyone else and he's also he's granted
like everything else so how do we know
especially how do you tell computer to
know that we should examine the specific
feature which is read to distinguish
from this person to the rest so if you
are a physician then of course the first
quite perfectly want to take is that to
look at the distribution of the
expression of genes in these cell
populations but the tradition if you if
a gene it's really expressed in the very
very small number of the cells the next
pression pattern the distribution will
look something like this where you have
this huge peak around the zero and they
will have almost a very negligible peak
that's at this high expression level
corresponding to the rare cells and the
traditional way of the analyzing these
cheese is that using these variants that
will be unable to identify these cheese
because the gene expression in only one
or two cells it would have almost a big
liberal effect on the global variance
so this problem we have been thinking
about for a long time and then we come
the stimulation but from reading these
the literature in economics so there is
a very well-defined statistics in the
social economic studies called the Gini
index which is also used to discover the
uneven income equality around the world
so we adopt this concept and trying to
identify the rare sometimes specific
genes the idea is the following so if
you take it every gene and then you sort
its expression kind of among the cells
from the lowest
the highest and then on the y-axis you
look at the total amount of the
transcription that a represented by
these set of the ourselves then what you
see is initially a very flat curve and
then in the end it will start to go up
if the expression level is only present
in the small number themselves however
if the cell if the screen expression is
evenly distributed across the cell types
then you will be saturate the diagonal
line therefore the area between this
diagonal line and this red curve will
give you a good measurement for the
inequality of these gene expression so
this is the key feature to select these
genes and then we add a number of
additional steps such a normalization
and the density based the class breeding
and so we put together a comprehensive
pipeline we call it the GD class they're
trying to identify the rare cell types
and that is a paper was recently
published and then we also have a
software that can be run and both as a
web application and also a command-line
application so just to give you a kind
of sense how well this method works that
we kind of used to these validation
experiments where we mixed a list of
bone marrow cells from the mouse with a
small number of the cells from the
different lineages one of that is the
intestines themselves multiply red and
the other one is the memory stem cells
multiply blue and what we want to know
is that can we use the Genie class to
recover these populations and the ANU
can see that the the truth here's the
truth of the on the left that is are the
two populations and on the right we see
the results that discovered by the Agena
class and then we see dpdx very high on
correspondence between the two and the
showing that the Gini index indeed come
from very well in identifying layer
populations so of course we are very
eager to upside this technology to
analyzing the rail Kennedy dataset and
one of the data says was published about
two years ago we didn't have a knowledge
either in job so what this does is to
look at the end differences ESL's to
qualify about the 2005 hundreds of these
cells and identified the gene expression
pattern see every one of those so by
using the Gini class when we found was
the stimulated rate of the rare class
they're busted by red which can only be
clearly visible when units will be a
discussion and we only identified in a
single rare plaster so we want to know
is it really real or just a technical
artifact so here's a slide where I'll
show that which keys that are actually
depression expressed between these rare
cell types retinal clusters and the
resin cells and you can see there's this
number of the genes that associated with
these count family and also this gene
called the TC stb-1 all of these genes
is actually they are known to be highly
expressed in this two cell stage which
unlike this traditional yourself
represents the total potency of
properties suggesting that amount is a
big population to yourself there might
exist a small fraction of these cells
until they possess is additional
differentiation potentials we thought
that's quite interesting discoveries
let me just switch the gears a little
bit and talk about another method that
we call this a scuba and the goal here
is trying to model it that makes doing
start appreciation
the worker was found by a former postdoc
in Guinea or Michael so the Ling idea is
that when we started think about it is
self days we tend to think that the
deltas are affixed but in reality the
actually the cells days are constantly
changing right so to find out the
dynamics of between expressions is
actually the key to understand the
functions of watching cell states and in
the mathematics there is a very nice
representation in this context of space
diagram so what I show is the expression
level of two genes a and B and you can
mention this is the actually there are
about 20,000 dimensions that you cannot
see where each of this dot it will be
lend to a expression level for a single
cell and you can see in this picture
there is a big circle that's kind of
like the center called attractor so what
it does is that if a cell that's
actually away from that and then tend to
be attracted to to displacer so that's
the why we call this Center at this
attractor and you can actually
intuitively imagine this it's the same
as the pattern where you throw a ball
down this kind of valley whereas the
attractor corresponds to the bottom of
the valley where the cells on the side
correspond to these from the notes so
you can also appreciate the fact that if
you perturb this valley landscape a
little bit about nudging a little bit in
the bottom
and instead of having one attractors you
could have two factors one left and you
want the right and then when you do that
you will see that actually there are two
attractions on left and actually they
separated by boundary spacing so this is
I need to take a little break is that
okay so what apply this idea to analyze
the real single-celled data so ideally
what we want is to follow the gene
expression patterns along the cell in
life cells as the differentiate that in
acting the reality which is you can only
do is that you take a snapshot and a
different time points of these allamanda
parents and buy one actually analyze one
of these datasets in the mouse or a
embryo and then we identify these kind
of developmental lineages with these two
branching points that you can see the in
so we call this as the bifurcation
points where our one homogeneous
populations that becomes two hero needs
populations we particularly focus on
these two directions so where these two
cell types are diverse and we call this
the occupation direction if you project
this high dimensional gene expression
data sets on this petition to rupture
then watching the scene is something
like this okay
consistent with the fact that you have
one on previous populations becoming two
distinct populations this is at the 16
cells of publication
to sell bifurcation and to model these
dynamics changes across along these the
bifurcation axis so use it is a
mathematical model but first discovered
by Rene tome in mathematician sixteenth
so you can look at this graph or at the
bottom that shows these two parameter
space a and B and the y-axis is shows
for each of this configuration
how many statuses that steady state see
so if you're in this in this kind of
colleague at the blue area when they're
actually three city-states one of them
is a stable and the other two are stable
these are the factors that you see
whereas on these green regions you only
see one steady states that the stable
States so the kind of bifurcation area
that you see earlier and correspond to
the movement from this group window to
this assumed zone so to mimic the factor
that there is actually a stochastic
noise in the system we add a noise term
in this equation and the distribution of
the cells actually can be written by
this the fokker-planck equation that
actually has analytical solutions to
that so if you apply this model to the
data sets I'll show you before you have
this noise looking into a potential
again
you see this is kind of one Valley at
the default specification that changing
tickets to valleys up to specification
so you know there why do you care about
these kind of the process so one of the
reasons that was in the care is because
it makes the specific predictions about
which kind of
regulators will lead to an imbalance in
this differentiation film images so
imagine that when you're in this
previous slide imagine that if you're
depending on where you are on this slope
on the valley that you may have a higher
or lower permeability than to fall into
the valley the left Valley in society
and based on our models that give you a
quantitative prediction of the exact day
of the every one of these pro actor
transcription factors which is shown
over here and actually we can externally
test these positions the way we did that
is that use the DS most mutant of the
nanog which have both some of the embryo
is the hence the homozygous and o'connor
some of them have it was like the snow
causes a Mach number but you know just
like well type each of the row is a
embryo and each of the column is a gene
so starting our model to this data and
you can actually see that the our model
can roughly speaking predicted the bias
that introduced the die these none of
perturbations whereas the using just
another expression law it does very very
poor job to that subacute Lisa kind of
position another fan operation that we
thought was very interesting but it has
yet to be experimental validated is
defective the noise noise is people many
people think that the noise it's
intrinsically in the deleterious
exactly but that there are some studies
also suggest that the noise could have
on the biological functions and in that
case what we predict is that the
magnitude of the noise actually could
influence the balance of these different
images if you have a very little noise
then preferential in most of the cells
they will be located in one of the two
outcomes whereas there are too big of
the noise that they will tend to be more
uniform industry
and it is possible that the noise level
is also subjected into developmental
control so let me just the talk briefly
about our ongoing work on Ariadne and so
this goal is trying to reconstruct the
developmental trajectories without prior
temporal information it's work was led
by talented graduate students we will
chair and a postdoc Lucas now so I will
just describe how they work so using
that kind of examples just to give you a
better idea so here we redesign in these
two Center data in the DOS don't marrow
bones bone marrow and each of the dots
represent a cell so we started with the
high dimension using structured data and
we project it into a most business space
by using this local linear embedding
technology and then next and we do is to
identify the clatters inside the stem
cells and the connections clusters by
using this for men in the same tree and
that give you a lineage representation
of these cell types now this still quite
not so intuitive housing of the
developmental trajectory progresses to
80 visualizations we actually plot a
two-dimensional tree we call it sub
soiler tree whereas the cell each of the
branches ents a kind of development of
lineage referred by the a minimal
spanning tree whereas the each of the
the distance between a cell to the
branch and that represents of the cow
currently that that cell is map to that
branch and from here which you can see
is that we start from the hematopoietic
stem cells we can be potential stem
cells and then one of the religions you
become this piece and then suddenly
viciously go to other religions to does
completely assisted with our know
biology what though we could also show
is the distribution of the cells at each
of this point along this tree and this
give you kind of a common information
about where the development of
bottleneck is for example you see that
in this first operations there's a vast
degree of these cells death suggested
that perhaps this ourselves the very
very cell cells the actual state at
these states so we could also look at
that this individual markers on history
and especially we can identify there
some markers that are differentially
expressed between the different lineages
and that we suggested that these genes
that may play a distinct role in the
make yourself great decisions so just to
summarize what I talked to you about
today I told you three methods our lab
developed and first it's called a genie
cost its investment trying to identify
the where sometimes and second method is
the scuba is trying to involve the
mimics of thinking expression doing so
differentiation when the master one is
called the Ariadne and it's not only we
construct the cell engines but also the
visualizes with the holiday so our
differentiation and it lasts not a
missile and we thank the people who have
done the work the land gel let the work
in developing research in across the
matter
you see neo led the world in the scuba
Luca and we doll led the world in
gravity and a lot of this experiment
worker would die in collaboration with
dr. Wharton's lives
specifically go geo who was a former
postdocs in the lab and that we also
suspect our banking agencies for support
and finally I will thank everybody for
pay attention and I'll be happy to take
any questions and us go
thank you dr. Yan to that informative
presentation thank you dr. Yan so that
was formative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green terminate button at the
lower left of the presentation window
touch your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many
questions as we can let's get started
the first question is are the tools
publicly available our public available
and posted both at our website and also
we posted the tools at the github Asia's
open source depository for all the
software
thank you the next question is what is
the difference between cells State and
cell types very interesting question so
that's actually are there's a lot of
debate in the community what you call
self a what you call a cell type and
there is not consensus actually so it's
basically a very intuitive way to think
about it is that the cell States is a
more or less a continuous representation
of the gene expression whereas the cell
type is more disk organized diversion of
Scindia of the description so what I
tend to think of its kind of my kind of
same result was that the cell types are
kind of like the attractors that you see
in one of the side that showed before so
it's a intrinsically stable its perturb
a little bit away from that they will
come back to that
so that's perhaps you know highly
regulated by other like gene expression
gene regulatory networks but the cell
phase can be you know the cloud that
around it so it's a intrinsically
stochastic but only if a if it's stable
then I'm like to count down as a subtype
that's very good questions
any additional questions will be
answered via email after the
presentation I would like to once again
thank dr. Yong for his presentation I
would also like to thank labyrinths for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2017 you will receive
an email from labrys letting you know
what this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye